Strong passwords help to prevent malicious people from accessing your information.
A good password is hard for other people to guess, but easy for you to remember.
Variations on words like "password" or "secret," dictionary words...
...and patterns on the keyboard like QWERTY or 12345,...
...generally don't make good passwords because they're too easy to guess.
Using a mix of upper and lowercase letters, numbers and symbols makes your password harder to guess.
Try starting with a random word or phrase like "I love sandwiches"...
...and inserting symbols, letters and numbers to make your password more secure.
But don't use that one because we have it in this video.
Be sure to use unique passwords for your different accounts, like your e-mail and online bank account.
And keep your password a secret, too.
It's something only you should know.